haben die krawalle von samstagnacht in
stuttgart etwas mit migration zu tun und
möglichen integrationsproblemen wenn wir
sehen dass mehr als die hälfte der
festgenommenen keinen deutschen pass
hatte
wenn wir aber auch in den vergangenheit
in der vergangenheit immer wieder
gesehen haben dass angriffe auf
rettungskräfte auf krankenwagen auf
feuerwehrwagen besonders häufig zum
beispiel in klein muss bei damit
verbundenen straftaten stattfinden haben
wir da integrations versagen gesehen
haben wir da mangelndem respekt
gegenüber der polizei bei menschen
gesehen die zu uns gekommen sind oder
hat es damit nichts zu tun
jedenfalls sollten wir es mit multikulti
nicht übertreiben multikulti hat seine
klaren grenzen in den geltenden gesetzen
insbesondere in den strafgesetzen und da
gibt es jedenfalls in stuttgart und in
baden württemberg keinerlei rabatt ich
will vielleicht auch noch einmal sagen
erreicht warum gerade jetzt
ich habe am gestrigen sonntag sehr früh
darauf hingewiesen dass diese art der
gewalttätigen ausschreitungen eine neue
qualität jedenfalls in stuttgart und
baden württemberg hat diese randale
diese plünderung von geschäften das hat
es bisher bei uns nicht gegeben
und das hat schon möglicherweise etwas
zu tun mit dem gesellschaftlichen umfeld
und auch mit den äußerungen der
bundesinnenminister hat darauf zu recht
hingewiesen die aus dem politischen
umfeld kommen es muss jetzt einfach
schluss sein mit den beschimpfen unserer
polizei mit dem diskreditieren von
polizistinnen und polizisten ja bis hin
zur verleumdung unsere polizei in
baden-württemberg aber in ganz
deutschland hat dank und respekt
verdient für ihre arbeit sieben tage die
woche 24 stunden am tag und nicht hass
und verachtung und schon gar keine
gewalt das muss jetzt auch einmal klar
sein und ich hoffe
dass diese schrecklichen bilder aus
stuttgart dem einen oder anderen auch in
der politik die augen öffnen dass wir
uns hinter unsere polizei und vor unsere
polizei zu stellen haben auch dann im
übrigen wenn das eine schwierige lage
ist herr seehofer allahu akbar rufe hört
man auf den videos aus stuttgart etwas
was sind ihre gedanken dazu
ja das ist für mich alles unfassbar ist
schrecklich es ist einmalig und deshalb
müssen wir gemeinsam alles tun
deshalb bin ich auch heute hier in
stuttgart ich werde mir dann auch die
schäden noch ansehen gemeinsam mit
thomas strobl dass sich das nicht
wiederholt das ist eigentlich jetzt die
größte aufgabe und das werden wir nur
erreichen wenn wir unseren worten als
politiker auch taten folgen lassen
es wird häufig bei solchen dingen viel
gesagt aber nach einigen tagen beruhigt
es sich dann wieder und es erfolgt nicht
das notwendige ich habe ein paar punkte
genannt die aus meiner sicht notwendig
sind die geändert werden müssen
insbesondere auch die konsequenz der
justiz gegenüber den straftätern und was
die migration angeht da werde ich mir
erst ein urteil erlauben wenn ich die
genaueren ermittlungsergebnisse kenne
ich kenne auch die zahl die sie genannt
haben aber es kommt immer darauf an ist
man hier geboren welchen weg hat man
hier gemacht ist man bereits polizei
stelle gewesen und so weiter und so fort
und dann muss man darüber ganz offen
reden was die ermittlungen der polizei
ergeben haben